bonsoir nouvelle édition de notre série
consacrée aux 40 ans de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline on a parlé ici d'architecture on
a parlé de logement on a parlé de
transport tout ça évidemment c'est
nécessaire pour la construction d'une
ville nouvelle mais une ville nouvelle
ne serait sans doute rien sans le tissu
associatif et c'est donc aux association
que nous allons consacrer cette émission
pour en parler Bertron Ouillon bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes vice-président chargé
de la vie associative à la communité
d'agglomération de ctinline donc
responsable du tissu associatif si je
puis dire au niveau de la la casquille
euh Jacques maréchal vous êtes le
fondateur de l'association animation
Agou qui est basée à hencour c'est un
quartier d'élancour et l'association a
fêté je crois c'est 34 ans hein donc oui
vous êtes un des pionniers du du milieu
associatif euh Jacques morni oui bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes vice-président de
l'Association Sportive de montigé le
Bretonneux qui alors une association
c'est l'une des plus anciennes hein sur
1971 ouais 40 ans vous avez fêté les 40
ans et et Jean y Vespier vous êtes le
vice-président et le fondateur des cœurs
de la playéade une chorale qui existe
aussi depuis un certain temps depuis 36
ans je crois oui 36 ans 1976 juillet
1976 voilà alors on va aborder trois
parties dans dans cette émission mais on
va tout de suite commencer par les
premières
années alors bah je me tourne vers vous
trois parce que vous êtes au fond le
plus le le plus jeune dans C 76 je suis
en 76 vous êes en 76 c'est ça voilà vous
êtes vous êtes arriv arrivé enfin vous
êtes né dans la région je suis né à
manilamo donc vous avez connu alors le
tissu associatif depuis depuis tout mais
vous êtes responsable aujourd'hui mais
c'est vrai que voilà il y aurait pas eu
ce que je que disais au début il y
aurait pas eu SaintQuentin sans les
associations non tout à fait tout à fait
la ville s'est développée de d'ouest en
est et les plus anciennes
effectivement sauf la votre se trouve
plutôt à l'ouest de la ville nouvelle
qu'à l'Est puisque l'urbanisation s'est
fait d'Ouest en Est et les gens sont
arrivés progressivement ben alors les PE
commencer par vous euh monsieur brchal
mais euh qu'est-ce qui fait que voilà on
se dit à un moment il faut créer un lien
entre les habitants donc l'association
c'est un c'est un moyen rêvé de créer ce
lien c'est ça oui bien sûr et d'abord
les gens se se connaissent parce qu'ils
habitent côte à côte ils sont ce qu'on
appelle mitoyens donc ils se voi il se
parle et puis on peut pas éternellement
simplement échanger sur le rhum du bébé
ou ou ou la cylindrée de la
voiture on fait des choses ensemble on a
eu une année exceptionnelle que l'année
76 je sais pas si vous souvenez il y a
eu une chaleur extraordinaire une
canicule fabuleuse tout le monde était
dehors et on faisait des fêtes le soir
et puis on a dit bon bah tout ça c'est
bien gentil mais c'est éphémère faudrait
créer quand même une structure qui nous
permet de nous retrouver de façon plus
régulière de façon un peu plus organisé
de faire des activités ensemble c'est un
peu comme ça que c'est né c'est ça
monsieur
même chose c'est plutôt le sport alorsou
c'est oui moi c'est plus le enfin le
sport on verra mais je veux dire il y a
il y a quand même dans les association
je parle sous votre contrôle mais il y a
beaucoup ou d'association culturelles
avec la corale notamment ou
d'association Sportiv c'est je crois que
c'est les deux les de choses qui sont le
plus représenté non dans les
associations c'est les deux éléments les
plus représentés en tout cas les de les
deux secteurs qui qui ont été parmi les
premiers avec l'ensemble des activités
sociocculturelles alors Jacques morni
oui donc en
1971 le le la ville la municipalité
s'est rendu compte qu'il n'y avait pas
du tout de développement sportif pas
d'équipe il y avait aucun aucune
animation sportive sur la ville de
Montini et donc il a été décidé de créer
laasmb l'assoociation sportive de
montiny le Bretonneux et c'est la
section
pétanque qui commencé qui qui a commencé
tout à fait avec quelques membres
quelques quelques adhérents puis au au
fil du temps euh un an après il y a la
gym d'entretien le yoga le foot qui sont
venus se greffer pour faire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a dans cette ASMB 20
sections différentes ce qui représente
5200 adhérents ça ve ça veut pas dire
pardon c'est comme ça mais est-ce que ça
veut pas dire qu'on a commencé d'abord
ce que disait un peu Jacques maréchal
tout à l'heure peut-être parler adultes
he la pétan c'est plutôt un truc de
copain et puis après on a pensé au
jeunes c'est tout à fait lié à ce qu'
vient direou la pét la pétan c'est
vraiment les amis qui qui se
réunissaient pour oui oui oui oui oui
absolument tout à fait ça et puis après
on a passé peut-être plus au jeunes avec
le foot avec il a fall construire il a
fallu construire aussi des des
installations hein parce que du foot du
foot dans la rue c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas tout à fait le lieu donc il a fallu
construire investir donc c'est pour ça
ensuite je pense que l'ensemble c'est
bien développé jepier vous la fondation
de de l'association alors c'est pas sur
strictement créer un lien local parce
que réunir une corale
classique mixte nécessite d'avoir un un
un bassin de population plus important
donc ça correspondait plus au besoins au
manque de de Coral de champ cororal sur
la partie justement ouest de la ville
nouvelle morpa et en cour et c'est comme
ça que ayant rencontré un chef de cœur
ayant sympathisé avec lui on a lancé
cette d'ailleurs des images des voilà
peut-être des premières réunions enfin
euh de de de votre corale oui euh et
donc oui c'est ça c'est c'était ça
répondait à un besoin de quelque chose
qui n'existait pasép un besoin culturel
besoin musical et c'est comme ça on a
commencé avec 30 ou 40
personnes beaucoup se connaissaient donc
c'était le noyau de départ on est passé
assez vite à 60 80 et c'est des gens qui
qui avaient déjà appartenu à des Corales
qui savaient chanter ou il y a aussi des
gens qui se
sontp oui des des gens des gens qui
avaient chanté ite il y a effectivement
des gens qui avaient envie de le faire
qui l'avaient jamais pratiqué et qui
nous ont rejoint alors euh il y a il y a
une chose chacun voilà on parlait de
l'ouest de l'Est c'est c'est d'abord des
associations qui dépendent de de
communes enfin l'identité elle est
communale au départ tout à fait jeaais
souligné au départ même si là on parle
d'initiative individuelle il est clair
que tout ça n'aurait pas pu éclore s'il
y avait pas eu une volonté politique à
l'époque des premiers élus de la ville
nouvelle et euh de l'établissement
public d'aménagement qui avait un poids
énorme dans le développement à
l'époquein il y a eu Organon au départ
années 73 74 par là qui a rapidement
laissé sa place à l'association de la
promotion des activités
socio-culturelles dont j'ai eu le
plaisir de présider pendant quelques
années et là c'était vraiment une
volonté politique d'organiser et de
d'être puissance organisatrice et et
régulatrice un petit peu de l'activité
euh alors là plutôt socioculturelle
puisque c'était euh la salle que l'on
connaît maintenant qui s'appelle le
prisme qui était le lieu était le lieu
alors justement puisque vous parlez de
l'Association pour la Promotion des des
activités sociocculturelles qui était
donc abrisé dans ce qu'on appelait la
Maison pour Tous Je je vous propose de
regarder un sujet d'archive justement
sur sur cette
maison dans l'esprit de ces promoteurs
la Maison pour tous est un lieu
d'accueil et de rencontre
pour les diverses couches de la
population en d'autres termes il s'agit
de favoriser la vie associative sans
pour autant se substituer aux
associations existantes vous trouverez à
la Maison pour tous différents services
un restaurant une cafétéria une halte
garderie un foyer pour personnes âgées
des salle de réunion un atelier de
reprographie sérigraphie offset ronéo
copie un service de prê de matériel un
centre de ressources
audioovisuelles une salle de spectacle
de 1100 places qui dès ce weekend sera
ouverte pour le spectacle de Raymond de
vos les portes sont désormais ouvertes
vous pouvez entrer tous les membres de
la pasque souhaitent que vous vous
sentiez au mieux chez
vous
alors peut-être une petite réaction sur
cette Maison pour tous vous avez connu
sa sa construction oui parce que moi
quand je suis arrivé en Ville-Nouvelle
elle' était pas fidie c'était encore des
briques qui s'empilaient les unes sur
les autres et il y a une chose qui était
remarquable aussi c'est que c'était en
même temps le restaurant du lycée
c'eston parlait d'un restaurant en fait
il y en avait deux il y avait un
restaurant public et le restaurant du
lycée ce qui permettait au lycéen d'être
au cœur de la vie culturelle
local et de connaître les spectacles les
associations enfin il y avait une vie là
qui était remarquable c'est dommage
quelque part que ce c'est disparu ça
alors ça on on va parler tout à l'heure
mais Bertrand Ouillon c'est au fond là
c'est c'est l'interaction entre bah la
vie des association et puis leur
activité et puis la volonté politique au
fond de cette maison pour tout ça c'est
c'est un peu la manifestation de ça à
partir du moment où on met des des gens
ensemble forcément il y a des liens et
en plus beaucoup de gens qui qui
connaissaiit pas du tout le coin qui qui
sont arrivés là et et qui qui avaiit
forcément un besoin de de rencontrer
d'autres de de pratiquer des activités
et et c'est vrai que à côté de ça on
avait il y avait un réseau des des élus
locaux qui était là aussi pour
accueillir ces nouveaux habitants et qui
et qui souhaitaent pouvoir mettre à
disposition tous les moyens possibles
pour que les gens puissent se connaître
et finalement s'investir aussi sur le
territoire c'est que depuis le début
enfin on a pris conscience au niveau
politique quoi de la nécessité de ces
associations et de la nécessité de de ce
tissu
associatif depuis le début sur sur 50
ans Yveline les
associations sont un moteur de la vie
locale et un moteur de l'animation
locale par exemple je suis né alors à
l'est sur de la de de C an en Yveline
sur manilamo euh sur cette commune là
c'est c'est clairement aussi les
associations qui ont euh qui ont
développé toute l'animation de la cité h
mais l'identité alors des des
associations est-ce que c'est voilà
SaintQuentin est-ce que c'est
l'agglomération est-ce que c'est la
ville nouvelle est-ce que c'est h encour
est-ce que c'est
Montini vous sentez appartenir à quoi
non moi je crois qu'il y a pas vraiment
de cocoric il y peut-être pas non plus
peut-être double appartenance d'ailles
enfin il y a des adhérents de de
différentes communes dans nos
associations bien sûr en étant implanté
pour 3 pour ce qui est de 3A à hencour
il y a bien sûr plus d'éencourtoi
certainement mais il y a pas mal de
mpasiens il y a des gens d'un peu
partout et l'identité locale est pas pas
très forte dans nos dans nos activités
c'est pas on n pas de bannière à
défendre dans des dans des dans des
rencontes ou des choses comme ça je veux
dire c'est pas euh jeanier quel a été je
disais tout à l'heure au début voilà
c'était des gens qui avaient envie de de
participer une Corelle qui était un peu
des des gens qui savaient chanter est-ce
que vous avez une évolution au fil du
temps dans votre association par exemple
alors je pense que le type d'association
euh un cœur euh nécessite un un
investissement on peut pas venir
consommer et on peut venir consommer un
un cours de de de yoga et ne pas
s'investir dans l'association eu le la
préparation d'un d'un d'un programme
qu'on va chanter en fin d'année c'est
vraiment tout le monde qui qui participe
donc euh il y a il y a un travail
collectif qui nécessite d'ailleurs un
peu d'investissement personnel euh qui
est aidé par des des formations que que
l'on
donne en technique vocale en solfge et
cetera donc on n'a pas trop évolué vers
vers l'association où il y a des
consommateur qui
arent qui repartent après et et et vous
avez aussi eu des des liens avec que les
institutions culturelles avec des
théâtres notamment alors effectivement
on a euh démarré avec la pasque parce
que il y avait très peu de de lieux où
on pouvait donner une représentation en
cœur de de 50 personn et une petite
orchestre d'accompagnement donc au
départ effectivement on avait à peu près
chaque année la possibilité de donner
une représentation à la pasque euh je
dois dire que la ville nouvelle a
ensuite évoluer d'une façon un peu
différente avec la création de lieu de
programmation de programmation de
théâtre notamment enfin de théâtre oui à
peu près dans toutes les
communes moi je dirais je suis peut-être
euh pas tout à fait juste je dirais au
au détriment des associations locales
c'est-à-dire que avec une politique de
de de programmation professionnelle
tout ce qui était pas étiqueté
professionnel pendant quelques années
est sorti carrément du du du giron les
salles étaient
inaccessible évoluon il y a eu ces deux
mouvements c'estàdire que je pense la
nécessité des des associations mais
aussi la le lien culturel hein ça a été
les je pense que les deux grands
mouvements de la création de de la ville
nouvelle de ce point de vue-l c'estd que
la culture était aussi devenue un un
moyen de lien social non
la culture la politique culturelle a été
un un des un des moyens justement de de
créer le lien social au niveau de au
niveau de C an nieline mais c'est vrai
que au
départ les élus ont ont accompagné et
ont donné les moyens de vivre disons aux
associations qui qui permettaient aux
gens qui arrivaient de se rencontrer
ensuite on a eu une très forte étape sur
la mise en place d'équipement euh
d'équipement parce que les associations
aussi demandent voilà tout à fait par
avec dans un instant mais mais c'est
c'est
voilàquip et donc ces équipements
étaient nécessaires pour la vie publique
de manière générale et aussi nécessaire
et demandé par les associations alors
après c'est vrai que Ben par exemple
avec l'arrivée du théâtre de
Saint-Quentin aussi euh il y a eu dans
le domaine culturel une
professionnalisation de ces endroits euh
aujourd'hui le l'ensemble des des salles
sont quand même assez assez bien
partagés entre le entre le le le
mouvement culturel professionnel euh
l'accueil de de troupes et cetera et
puis les
activités associatives qui ont
aujourd'hui toutes leur place même
parfois au côté des professionnels dans
le cadre des résidences d'arcistes et
cetera d' Chac mi alors la la petite
association de joueurs de pétan des
années 70 elle grandit énormément quoi
dans les années 80 absolument alors elle
grandit dans les années 80 mais
doucement dans les années 80 il doit y
avoir 800 membres ah oui ce qui est pas
mal comme évolution 8 an pour dire
aujourd'hui ENF 5 5200 je rebondis sur
ce que dis tout tout à l'heure nous on
se on se plaît de dire que le notre
sponsor principal c'est bien entendu la
municipalité la mairie parce que les
affastructur de Montini toutit deontini
parce que les les infrastructures les
les les stades enfin tous les
équipements sportifs sont nécessaires
pour une manifestation une association
sportive donc là là c'est sûr que la
mairie et je pense également l'ensemble
de la de la ville nouvelle à bien œuvrer
pour que pour que ça grandisse si vous
permettez à desemp à Montin il y a CIN
gymnases ce qui est quand même euh
beaucoup il doit y avoir j'ai compté 15
cours de tennis sur des différents ce
qui est pas mal aussi et il doit y avoir
10 terrains j'ai compté d'une seule fois
foot et rugby donc 10 terrains de foot
et de rugby dans une ville de 3000
habitants000 habitants à peu près he
Montin il y a que Montini qui s'en ser
ou
ça non Montini s'en sert en priorité
mais c'est TER c'est ouvert et ça sert
pour pour les rencontres mais justement
on parle de la croissance des
association et et bien un moment voilà
il a fallu construire des locaux pour
votre association on va regarder un
sujet c'est justement sur cette
construction installé temporairement
dans une ancienne école du pas du lac
l'Association Sportive de Montini et ces
différentes sections vont bientôt
prendre possession de leur nouveaux
locaux juste à proximité du parc de la
coudre le chantier va s'achever en mai
2009 l'objectif c'est de loger correct
l'ensemble de l'Association Sportive de
montinille bronneux avec sa ses 17
sections ces locaux sont nécessaires
pour une grosse structure comme la SMB
qui a du personnel à demeure qui a
besoin de faire beaucoup de réunions sur
le plan technique le bâtiment a été
réalisé en fonction des dernières normes
environnementales des capteurs solaires
permettront d'assurer l'eau chaude et
l'eau pluviale sera récoltée pour
assurer l'arrosage du terrain de foot
adjacent coûte de la réalisation 1300000
€ finan par la Communauté
d'Agglomération la mise à disposition de
cet édifice ne semble pas avoir créé de
tension avec les autres association avec
les autres associations ça se passe
relativement bien puisque je pense que
laasmb n'est pas
sectaire donc le jour où ils ont besoin
d'une salle de réunion par exemple ils
peuvent très bien leur prêter leur salle
de réunion ça ne pose aucun
problème
Jacques maréchal bon les associations
c'est évidemment de la convivialité
c'est le lien social c'est le le vivre
ensemble mais c'est aussi ça a aussi des
un impact économique tout à fait c'est
c'est même des porteurs d'emploi et je
dirais même d'emploi durable je pense à
à l'association 3A moi j'avais embauché
un prof de danse en 79
elle est toujours là et c'est son métier
c'est son travail elle en a vécu elle
envie toujours très
bien depuis depuis qu' qu'on l' embauché
donc on a créé un emploi durable il y a
l'équivalent dans l'association je
dirais de TR tempss plein à peu près bon
pour une petite association c'est c'est
300 personnes 3 300 350 personnes autre
exemple l'Agence Locale de l'énergie
l'ALC que j'ai créé avec Alain
levote en 2000 c'est emplois permanents
et c'est pas des
emplois que j'entends certains dire les
vrais emplois bon les vrais emplois je
suis désolé c'est des vrais emplois
c'est des emplois durables c'est des
emplois pérennes et qui sont pas qui
fonctionnent pas avec de l'argent public
qui fonctionne comment fonction d' des
associationsation subventions dans le
cadre des gens qui pratiquent une
activité les gens qui pratiquent une
activité payent leur activité donc c'est
pas de l'argent public c'est de l'argent
dans le cadre par exemple de l'Agence
Locale de l'énergie ce sont des gens qui
font des
prestations c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas la ville d'Intel ou la le
département qui donne de l'argent comme
ça dans un puissant fond je pense qu'il
faut il faut bien voir que les
associations je pense que pour le sport
c'est pareil il y a un nombre
d'animateurs un nombre de professeurs
qui sont payés pour mener ces
activitésbi d'emplois SMB cré des
emplois 33 emplois
partiel partiels partiel cor non alors
pendant longtemps on a eu la chance
d'avoir un chef de cœur bénévole
euh maintenant il est rémunéré c'est un
emploi partiel mais par contre tous les
concerts que nous avons donnés
et nous avons soit embaucher directement
des des solistes donc des intermittents
du spectacle ce sont des des CDI mais
des intermittents du spectacle dans le
monde musical heureusement qu'ils ont
des associations euh pour leur procurer
des des des prestations puis nous avons
fait travailler des orchestres
l'orchestre de C1 niveline l'ensemble
d'orchestral saquanttin nveline quand il
a fonctionné et puis d'autres d'autres
orchestres donc effectivement c'est
aussi une activité économique économique
importante Manton alors l'avenir des
associations euh comment vous le voyez
est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui est en train de
changer qu'est-ce
que ce que ce qu'on voit depuis depuis
maintenant les 40 ans on est passé
d'association disons militante de de
fort engagement de de la part des des
adhérents à des associations où les gens
qui s'inscrivent sont peut-être un peu
plus consommateurs d'activité d'une
année sur l'autre peuvent changer avec
peut-être moins d'attach dans le
nouvelle population aussi qui arrive il
y a aussi nouvelle une nouvelle
population et puis desidentité peut-être
pas le même que qu'au début exactement
les voilà les gens ont plus forcément
puisqu'ils sont là depuis maintenant
aussi pour beaucoup euh pour beaucoup
assez longtemps c'est peut-être les
enfants les petits- enfants aujourd'hui
euh qui qui arrivent dans ces
association qui euh qui sont déjà bien
établis bien installés avec justement
les équipements publics qui ont été
créés par la communauté d'agglomération
pour accompagner les commune donc on a
aujourd'hui plus voilà une consommation
d'activités euh et puis euh aujourd'hui
un un défi à relever pour l'ensemble des
associations de Saint-Quentin euh qui
est le renouvellement des dirigeants et
le renouvellement des bénévoles avec un
manque du statut du bénévole au niveau
national on est disons aujourd'huiz des
gens pour prendre votre suite très
difficile de trouver des trouver desveau
des bénévoles ou c'est pas facile
alors voilà non c'est c'est c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui le rôle maintenant des
des communes et est de revenir justement
à un accompagnement de ses bénévoles de
ses dirigeants de de les aider à se
former aussi puisque ils ont une
responsabil
de plus en plus for avec des démarches
administraes aussi qui sont rend
compleabilé compqu des responsabilités
qui n'étai pas forcément cherché en tout
cas il y a 4
an des responsabilités au niveau
économique aussi avec voilà les
associations les dirigeants
d'association sont des employeurs pour
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est comme vous
disz des vrais emplois il faut bien il
faut bien le répéter et et du coup voilà
les communes et la communaé
d'agglomération doivent de les
accompagner de leur faciliter la tâche
de leur mettre à disposition le plus
facilement possible des équipements du
matériel des financements aussi pour
pour les aider à vivre dans leur
fonctionnement et puis de pouvoir leur
donner des moyens de formation c'est ce
qu'on a créé justement avec le service
du associatif de saint-gantin alors
pardon je je vous propose de voir un un
sujet sur une association aussi parce
que les associations ça sert aussi à ça
qui a découvert des gens comme sopia
de c'est le déclic théâtre d' formidable
association je propose de regarder un
sujet qui lui est consacré je viens
faire mon spectacle quel est le point
commun entre Jamel de Bou je su même pas
payé en plus ce
soir Laurent Ournac
ou encore Arnaud samère oh
non il n'y a plus de papier non ce n'est
pas possible
et bien tous sont passés par la case
Déclic Théâtre une compagnie de théâtre
pas comme les autres puisqu'elle cultive
le théâtre d'improvisation un genre venu
tout droit du Québec et c'est à trappe
que Déclic Théâtre a vu le jour en
1993 à l'époque Jamel et collégien et
découvre l'improvisation grâce au
directeur artistique de la compagnie
Alain dega surnommé papi Jamel dira
d'ailleurs qu'il doit tout à cet homme
car papi finalement c'est un découvreur
de talent exemple avec Arnaud sa mère
avez-vous entendu parler parler de cet
humoriste régulier de l'émission On ne
demande qu'à en rire présenté par
Laurent Ruquier la rencontre de tè avec
papy a été décisive pour la carrière du
jeune artiste quand à 25 ans 26 ans tu
lâches ton boulot un CDI avec un salaire
fixe et que tu tu veux avoir ton et que
tu veux faire du spectacle ton métier la
première chose la première question
c'est de savoir comment je vais bouffer
et et Papi m'a tout de suite rassuré
là-dessus et puis il m'a donné il m'a
tout de suite montré beaucoup de
confiance et il m'a tout de
suite m'a tout de suite fait comprendre
que c'était pas une décision inepte et
et donc ça a été très important pour moi
et la succès story de declictat ne
s'arrête pas là à l'affiche de la
comédie Beur sur la ville le comédien
Issa dumbia lui aussi issu de la
compagnie d'improvisation quand je suis
arrivé dans l'atelier mon prof c'était
Jamel Debou qui est aujourd'hui un grand
acteur grand comédien et que tout le
monde connaît Déclic Théâtre vraiment
c'est c'est vraiment ma ma seconde
famille parce que ils ont toujours été
là au moment où il fallait dans ma vie
quand j'étais timide donc je fait des
cours avec eux après quand je traînais
dans la rue ils étaient là et après
quand j'ai voulu vraiment faire ce que
je voulait donc être complètement
comédien et ben ils ont encore été là
depuis peu ny pimort Antoine Rabo et
Julie Galibert trois anciens élèves de
Déclic Théâtre ont rejoint la chaîne
canalj pour animer une émission jeunesse
déjantée peut-être suivront-ils les pas
de sopia Haram qui adolescente
improvisait au côté de Jamel de Bou
après avoir débuté dans l'audiovisuel
avec Arthur la comédienne s'épanouit
désormais sur les planches alors même si
déclic thâre ressemblent à une réelle
star academmy c'est loin du star système
que la compagnie est obligée de se
battre au quotidien pour obtenir des
subventions et assurer ainsi la survie
de sa
structure le déclic théâre donc
peut-être un je crois que vous avez une
anecdote sur tous les ans à 3 au début
on faisait une soirée cabaret et puis on
faisait venir donc Bernard Joyet qui est
un chanteur connu maintenant et puis une
année il pouvait pas et donc je demande
à un de mes copains de trappe s'il
connaissait il me dit bah écoute je
connais papi je vais lui poser la
question il y a pas mal de jeune
là-dedans bon très bien on fait la
soirée je vois arrivé ce ce jeune beurre
avec un un bras qui avait c'est handicap
et puis j'aiis à raconter nous a fait
rire extraordinaire euh bon pu Mo j'ai
oublié complètement son nom et puis un
jour je le revois je c'est chamelle
debout et le truc marrant c'est qu'il
avait été intervé dans l'Express une
fois il avait raconté cette anecdote et
il avait dit qu' c'était fait engueulé
par sa mère ou qu'il avait trè qu'il
avait eu très peur parce qu'on donnait
une petite une petite enveloppe et il
avait peur de se faire engueuler par sa
mère parce qu'on lui demandant mais d'O
d'où vient cet argent
quoi alors peut-être un mot de
conclusion sur les associations euh
voilà c'est c'est le le le ce qui se
passe maintenant c'est une sorte de
professionnalisation au fond des
associations ça devient des PME qu oui
oui je pense que je parle de PME parce
que c'est vraiment on doit réagir
maintenant comme une PME c'est on doit
être structurer chaque section je parle
pour les 20 sections chaque section doit
être structurée avec un
président un secrétaire et surtout un
trésorier le trésorier a un rôle très
important parce que tous les tous les
ans on a affire à un commissaire au
compte qui vient éplucher les comptes et
voir s'il y a pas de l'argent qui part
de droite et de gauche sans justificatif
donc je vous assure que c'est un travail
très sérieux et puis et puis on a du mal
à trouver des volontaires
donc merci merci merci à tous les quatre
voilà l'émission sur les associations
est terminée mais enfin ce que vous
racontez au fond c'est un peu la rançon
de la gloire c'est ça ça pourrait être
la conclusion merci à tous les
quatre